then on offline or bacharael
was actually with emma so uh
somehow it feels like quite a privilege
to now be talking about my research
right after her
um all right uh so i guess
each of us gave our little kind of uh
motivation for why we're interested in
this topic
uh and i'll give mine which is maybe a
little bit different
i'll start with something kind of
perhaps a little grandiose but i'll
bring it back down to earth
so um to over generalize grossly
if we want to ask the question you know
why why does current modern machine
learning work
uh you know at the risk of offending
everyone we could say that well it
really comes down to two big things and
then
a whole lot of details and the two big
things if you had to pick two really big
things
it would be access to large data sets
and the ability to train very large
models
plus all the things that we as
researchers actually do in our you know
in our actual research
but i think it's fair to say that
without large data sets and large models
we probably wouldn't see this tremendous
explosion in powerful machine learning
tools
that are actually used in practice and
domains from image recognition
to machine translation to speech
recognition
so to me offline reinforcement learning
is really interesting
because i see it as a vehicle that could
bring the benefits the power of these
large data sets and large models to the
decision making setting
so what's going on with reinforcement
learning well reinforcement learning
is uh kind of in the textbook setting
like literally if you open up the
sutnumbardo textbook
is described as an active process where
you have an agent that interacts with
the world
collects a sample of data use that to
improve its behavior
improve its policy or value function and
then do this all over again
and this recipe works quite well in a
range of settings like
you know playing games board games
simple robotics tasks etc
but if you want to take it to a setting
where you have very large data sets and
you want to get generalization
kind of real world open world
generalization then in this
active paradigm what you're looking at
is the possibility that you need to
collect
kind of image net size data sets each
time you modify your policy
and that's quite impractical if each
time your let's say autonomous car
changes policy a little bit
you need to you need to go back out and
drive in you know
30 different cities in north america
that would just not be a scalable
approach
and in fact if we look at the kind of
application areas where
reinforcing learning has been
tremendously successful and the kind of
areas where supervised methods have
succeeded
we see that there's a really big gulf
it's a gulf of generalization
the supervised learning methods are
using large data sets and huge models
to generalize across open world domains
whereas the reinforcement learning
methods are doing very well in terms of
control
but primarily in more narrow closed
world domains
and i think this is due to the
difficulty of leveraging large
data sets so can we develop data driven
rl
those are all methods that can emit
large data sets i think to get there
as uh you know we've heard from the
other speakers
we need to start thinking about how to
develop methods that can utilize
previously collected offline data so
these are methods that are called batch
rl
i'm i'm calling them offline rl just
because i think that term is a little
more descriptive
but you know that they're it's the same
exact thing bash rl or offline r
uh and i think a more realistic formula
for these kinds of algorithms
uh as opposed to this active online
setting would be something where
you have a large data sensor data set of
previous interaction data that the agent
has collected
doing whatever it is it was doing maybe
from human demonstrations maybe from its
own past experience
and that large dataset serves as sort of
the foundation for every skill or
behavior that it's going to try to
acquire
in the same way that imagenet can serve
as you know pre-training for downstream
visual perception tasks of course you
don't have to have a purely offline
system you could then say well let's go
back in and collect a little more data
to fix it up
but in some ways that's kind of not the
difficult part if you can get an initial
moderately competent policy from offline
data that's sort of the bit uh that
would be the
the main enabling factor for a lot of
what we'd like to do
and of course this could be a path to
get robotic systems that can interact
with
uh you know objects in the world but i
think it's also a path to
get reinforced and learning to work in
many other domains that traditionally
have been difficult for applying
rl algorithms like the domains that emma
mentioned
things like education medical diagnosis
scientific experimentation
there are also plenty of applications in
logistics operations research etc
which look like decision making problems
but are very hard to attack with
reinforcement learning methods today
if they require this online active
interaction
all right so in today's talk what i'm
going to discuss is
why offline rl is difficult and i'll
show a few experimental results
a lot of this is going to echo some of
the points raised by earlier speakers
uh how can we design offline rl
algorithms and then in the last portion
i'll concentrate on a
recent algorithm that we've developed
called conservative q learning
which seems to work fairly well in
practice
okay so let's start with uh the first
question
uh i think this is probably something
that i don't really need to go into
detail
on for this audience but as a quick
primer for of paul's crl methods a lot
of what i'll discuss focus on
qe learning algorithms for a q learning
algorithm you have your usual mdp
formulation with states actions rewards
and actions
your goal is to maximize the expected
reward of your policy and the object
that you will use to do this is the q
function which is the expected reward
that you'll get
if you start in a particular state in
action and of course the q function has
this very appealing property
that if you can enforce the bellman
equation on your state in action space
then you can recover the optimal policy
from that q function and
uh the way we do this is by minimizing
the difference between the left hand
side and right hand side of the bellman
equation
so hopefully we're all good with that
this talk is going to focus entirely on
these approximate dynamic programming
q-learning methods
but of course there are other methods
for offline rl2 that have nothing to do
with q functions which i will
completely gloss over
okay so the high-level sketch of a
off policy queue learning algorithm this
is basically kind of the third queue
iteration sketch
would look something like this you
collect some data set of transitions
using
whatever policy you want sample a batch
from that data set
minimize the difference between the
left-hand side and right-hand side of
the bellman equation
and if you'd like to do so go back out
and collect more data every once in a
while
and it's perhaps uh helpful to
think of this visually as this kind of
parallel process where you have your
your
data set you're crunching on your data
set improving your q function and
occasionally go back out and collect
more data from the world
and in offline rl the only change we
make is we skip this step
so we don't collect more data so it
might seem like well maybe
all is good we have this very nice off
policy framework based on
q functions can't we just use that to
solve all of our offline rl problems
uh and in fact we actually did some
experiments to try to
see if this could be the case to see if
essentially q-learning style algorithms
could serve as the basis for an offline
rl framework that's compatible with
large real-world data sets so this is an
experiment we ran
a couple of years ago at google where we
developed a salground called qt opt you
can think of it as basically a
continuous action version of q-learning
ran a large highly paralyzed experiment
with lots of robots collecting data
and then we wanted to see if data from
previous experiments could be used to
train up effective policies that
generalize to
new options so usually when i talk about
this method i show some videos
in kind of a robotics context and talk
about how you know it works pretty well
but what i want to talk about today
actually is how this experiment
informed some of our thinking about the
difficulty of the offline rl
problem so the resulting system it's an
image-based grasping system it works
very well in the real world
it can pick up objects as never seen
before but
uh one experiment that we actually did
in that paper that i often don't mention
is we actually compared what happens if
you take a previously collected data set
from past experiments
and just train up your q function on
that versus then fine-tuning it a little
bit more with on policy data collection
the amount of data available to in these
two regimes is pretty similar
the additional amount of online fine
tuning is less than
five percent of the of the original data
set size
um but the difference in performance is
actually pretty significant so the
purely offline version of this algorithm
has a success rate of 87 on previously
unseen
novel objects the fine-tuned one is 96
percent
now you can say these are both big
numbers but if you flip them around and
look at failure rates
the failure rate for the offline method
is more than three times larger
than the online fine-tuned method so
uh something is going on here there's
clearly a big price that we're paying
from doing offline training even in this
very large data regime
and we might want to try to understand
why that is
so my students overall kumar and justin
who ran some smaller controlled
experiments to try to understand this
question we had a few hypotheses to
think about
one hypothesis was well maybe if you
just train too long
with these approximate dynamic
programming methods you end up getting a
kind of overfitting
problem um so we tried uh
taking an offline data set for the half
cheetah task and training on that
this is with sac but you would get
probably the same thing with uh with
regular q learning sacs an actual critic
method
and we varied the data set size from one
million all the way uh
sorry from 1 000 all the way to 1
million so blue is 1 000 red is 1
million
and you can see that there's basically
no change in performance as the data set
size increases so this is not what you
would expect
from classic statistical overfitting
um if we actually look at how well the q
function thinks it's doing
now uh something very strange is going
on so the y
axis here is actually a log scale so the
rewards are all kind of between negative
500 and 500
but you know for the 1000 size data set
it thinks it's
getting 10 to the 20th power in terms of
its return
now that is clearly uh quite a bit
larger than what it's actually getting
so not only is the performance not
improving with the data set size
it's also overestimating enormously by
many many orders of magnitude
um another hypothesis we had well maybe
the training date is just not good
that's definitely not the case if we
cherry pick the best trajectories and
behave or clone them we get great
results so
good data is in there and it's not
overfitting so what is it doing well
a 10-use talk kind of alluded to this
point already
but essentially the problem is one of
the distributional shift if you solve
an empirical risk minimization problem a
supervised learning problem where you
minimize the difference between f of x
and y
on some input distribution p of x
you could ask the question given some
new x star is f of x star correct what
you can
promise if you're not getting
overfitting is that if you did well
in terms of empirical risk minimization
and you didn't overfit then you would
expect
that the expected value of your error on
new samples from the same distribution
would be low
but you can make that same promise for
samples from some other distribution
and even if you have a sample drawn from
your distribution
you can make this a point wise guarantee
so the thing that you can promise is
you'll be good on your training
distribution
now you could say usually we don't worry
about this because well we're doing d
bar l so we train
giant deep nets and they just generalize
because they're deep nets
um that is in some cases kind of a
reasonable argument but not so in the
reinforcement learning setting
because we're doing something much worse
than testing our function approximator
on auto distribution inputs we're
actually selecting our inputs
to be the arc max of our functional
approximator when we're doing q learning
uh and that's really bad news so if you
imagine that this is my function
and this blue thing is the neural net
that i fitted to this function
maybe it gets fairly low errors in most
places but if i take the r
max i'm going to precisely pick out that
peak that gets the largest error
and that's really really bad so
where do we suffer from distributional
shift in approximate dynamic programming
or q learning methods
well it's basically in that max so you
could rewrite the max as the expected
value
under some new policy so if your new
policy is just the r max the greedy
policy
that's that's how you get the q learning
update and
now looking at this you can see that in
order to evaluate our target values
we need to take an expected value under
some distribution pi
nu and we trained our q function
under some other distribution pi beta pi
beta is our behavior policy the thing
that collected our data
and pi beta is not in general equal to
pi nu so if it was equal we would expect
our target values to be all good
but since it's not equal then really all
bets are off so we expect good accuracy
when pi beta is equal to pi nu but
often does not really happen if we're
improving our policy that's
not actually the case that we're in and
even worse we're selecting pi nu to be
this arg max which is just like the
situation on the previous slide where
you're actually picking out the worst
errors in the positive direction
so that's really bad and that pretty
much explains why we get this massive
overestimation
when we try to use these methods in the
offline setup
okay so how have people gone about
addressing this issue
well uh one way that you could address
it is you could limit the amount of
distributional shift that you'll permit
so you could say well let's have some
actor critic style way of doing this it
doesn't actually have to be after critic
you can
impose the constraint implicitly but
it's easier to think about as actor
critic
where you will update your q function as
the expected value under pi new
but when you compute pi new you will
constrain it to stay close to the
behavior policy with some kind of
divergence constraint it could be kl
divers it could be something else
and the idea is that if you stay close
to pi beta then distributional shift
will be constrained
and this solves distributional shift
right
so you have no more erroneous values and
in fact
this kind of policy constraint style
method is a fairly old idea
it goes by many different names and it's
been used in quite a number of recent
papers
that use it as a way to get offline rl
to work better
but it does have a couple of issues one
issue which thing you also alluded to
is that it might be way too conservative
uh the one way to think about this is
let's say pi beta is just a random
policy
then limiting the the distributional
shift against pi beta essentially limits
how deterministic your new policy can be
it says that while you just have to be
pretty random otherwise the distribution
will shift is too large
that's uh often not not very good you
can partially mitigate this with using a
support constraint instead of a kl
divergence constraint
but it's still a pretty significant
issue the second issue is that
estimating the behavior policy to even
enforce this constraint
is itself very difficult especially on
real-world data
where the behavior policy might be very
complicated it might
you know you might have data from human
demonstrations or from policies that are
themselves you know not the result of
reinforcing learning maybe even manually
design policies
so it might be very hard to estimate pi
beta we actually did some experiments to
study how hard it is
in the in these experiments what we're
trying to do is pre-train a policy with
offline reinforcement learning and then
fine-tune it with online rl
and we tested some policy constraint
methods
so what you're seeing in this plot is
the left side is showing offline
training
and the right side is showing online
fine-tuning for a policy constraint
method
the y-axis is the log likelihood of the
estimated behavior policy so this is not
showing performance it's actually
showing how well is it estimating the
behavior policy
and it does fairly well in the offline
setting when given data from an easy
behavior policy but once it starts
fine-tuning it gets data from a mixture
of different policies
and then the behavior policy estimate
drops
very precipitously and this makes the
method actually unable to improve
so that's the yellow line in this curve
and this is also corroborated in some
more recent work that shows that
more powerful estimators for behavior
policies tend to lead to improvement
across the board
suggesting that's the bottleneck for a
lot of methods
one of the things you can do is you can
actually avoid estimating behavior
policies
by using implicit constraints um so the
idea here is that
if you write down this constraint policy
update you can actually write down the
lagrangian of this constrained
optimization problem
uh and uh if you then
try to write down the solution for the
uh you know the for pi star for this
constraint optimization problem you can
express it in closed form
as a function of the advantage and the
lagrange multiplier lambda
this is a trick uh that's borrowed from
some previous work the first the first
place where i saw it was actually
a paper by john peters called reps but
i'm sure it's come up in other places as
well
and it's fairly straightforward to show
by duality
the nice thing about this expression is
that because the optimal policy is given
by pi
beta times a bunch of other terms you
can approximate it by a maximum
likelihood with some weights so you can
optimize
pi new by maximizing an expression like
this where you take an expected value
under pi beta so that
accounts for the pi beta term being
multiplied into the
closed form solution of log pi times the
weights
and when you do this the nice thing is
you don't need to know what pi beta is
all you need is samples from the data
set and the credit can give you the
advantage
so we use this id in a number of recent
papers shown at the bottom of the slide
but one of the things that i want to
talk about in the last portion of this
talk is
maybe all this constraint business can
be avoided altogether if we can solve
the overestimation problem
at its root okay just
to jump in quickly so about three four
minutes left thank you thank you
um yeah so that's the idea in in a new
algorithm that we developed called
conservative q learning
conservative q learning doesn't aim to
directly constrain the policy to be
close to the behavior policy
but instead it aims to avoid
overestimation
so uh the problem that we saw before was
that when we train from offline data
we get these out of distribution
problems and we overestimate massively
so what if we can basically find these
places
where we're overestimating the true
function and basically push down on them
so that's the idea behind conservative
cue learning the expression here shows
the original kind of q-learning
objective minimizing the difference
between the left-hand side and the
right-hand side of the bellman equation
with an additional regularizer that
tries to find actions
for which the q value is large and
minimize their q value
so mu here is a distribution that shows
an adversarial to maximize q values
and this term pushes down on those q
values so it tries to specifically find
these peaks
and push them down which would correct
this overestimation problem
it turns out that if you have this
regularizer you can actually show that
for an appropriate chosen value of alpha
q hat pi will underestimate q pi
everywhere meaning that it will provide
a lower bound everywhere here means
for all actions on the states in your
data set
but the states in your data set are of
course the only ones you use to train
your
policy so that's what we want
so the algorithm is basically learn your
lower bound q function for your current
policy
such that it's a lower bound and then
take your
train your policy to be the arg max for
this lower bound q function and repeat
so basically actor critic with lower
bound q functions
it turns out that we can actually show a
better bound a tighter bound
if we modify this objective with an
additional term that also pushes
up on the samples from the data so you
push down on all the samples
that have high q values and you push up
on all the samples in your data set
the idea here is that if your policy
perfectly matches the data
these two terms perfectly balance out
and their contribution is zero
as you start overestimating the first
term uh becomes larger and then it gets
pushed down and that corrects the
overestimation
in this case we can no longer guarantee
that you have a lower bound for
all actions but you can still guarantee
that you have a lower bound in
expectation for your policy
which is of course what we actually want
because we're going to use this
to train our policy to update our policy
so you're going to minimize the big q
values and maximize the q values
for the state action tuples in your data
set this is the form of the bound that
we end up proving
in the paper so it has this pessimism
term to the regularizer so this part is
always positive
and then it has an error term due to
essentially sampling error so this
depends on a
on a constant that that uh quantifies
the basic
the concentration inequality so so long
as you choose alpha to be big enough
to overpower the sampling error we'll
get a bound
okay so does this bound hold in practice
uh we evaluated this experimentally
so what we're going to measure
experimentally is underestimation versus
overestimation so we evaluate the
expected value of our
learned q function minus the x
the true expected value which we
evaluate with monte carlo samples
uh and we evaluated this for our for two
variants of our method cql
and this cql equation one is just the
first version represented without that
second term
which has a less tight bound and then we
have four different kinds of ensembles
and our previous algorithm there and
what you can see is that both of the cql
methods have a negative difference which
means they're both underestimating
and the version with the second term is
a tighter bound so the bound actually
does hold in practice
whereas the prior methods generally all
have pretty wild optimism
to evaluate this method we used our
newly developed
benchmark suite for offline rl called
d4rl which the previous two talks also
mentioned
d4rl has quite a variety of different
tasks including
tasks that have real human data where
data doesn't just come from another rl
policy
tasks that require stitching parts of
trajectories so you have a multitask
data set
where you have agents performing a
variety of different tasks
maybe they go from a to b and separately
from b to c you need to stitch together
those parts to figure out how to go from
a to c
which is what we want from offline rl uh
you know there's more realistic tasks
like
driving in karla manipulating objects
with a robotic arm and this traffic
simulator from professor alex bynes
group called flow
so these tasks are meant to be a little
more representative of the kind of data
sets we see in the real world
if we look at the performance of of cql
so first let me present the baselines
i'm specifically just pointing out
kind of the harder tasks in the data set
in the paper we also have the results on
the more standard tasks
but the heart of the task is anthony's
which requires stitching
adroit which is the five finger hand and
kitchen which is that robotic arm
on a lot of these tasks we found that a
lot of previously proposed offline rl
methods don't tend to work very well a
lot of them are benchmarked on
data that comes from rl policies when
you have these harder data sets
it works uh quite a bit worse in fact
one of the strongest baselines
is simply behavior coding your entire
data set and that's of course bad news
if behavior cloning your data set works
better
than prior offline or all methods it
means these tests are actually pretty
tough
uh cql ends up doing quite a bit better
across the range of these tasks
up to five times better on many of the
hand tasks 1.5 to 3x better one has just
the human demonstrations
10 to 30 percent better than behavior
cloning on on the kitchen tasks
uh and behavioral clone is the strongest
baseline on these and it's actually
infinitely better on the larger and
mazes because previous methods are
actually unable
to get non-zero returns on these tasks
so this in a sense shows that those
tasks
are solvable because cql can get
non-zero returns
we also tested it on some atari games
using a data set from agarwal at all
where again we saw very substantial
gains
1.5 to 6x better so it seems that cql
seems to work pretty well in many of
these tasks and the thing that i'm
actually the most excited about is that
we seem to have some idea for why it
works because it has this kind of lower
bound property
um of course there's still plenty of
room for improvement so these scores are
normalized from 0 to 100
which means that we you know in
principle future work could do quite a
bit better
okay so to conclude i talked about how
offline rl is quite powerful and has
enormous promise
if we can just get it to work properly
uh you know effective offline rl methods
can be implemented by opposing some
constraints perhaps
implicitly but if we can avoid these
constraints and learn conservative q
functions instead then it appears
empirically like we can actually do
quite a bit better
all right thank you very much for
listening and i'd be happy to take some
questions
thank you so much circa this is
fantastic uh let's indeed open up the
floor for questions
okay well let me start then um
this is actually a question sergey that
that that also pertains to the other
talks but i think you you
you talked about the most of the the
results at the beginning
um how much of
how much of the success of different
methods is going to depend on how the
data is collected
right so with the and tasks you're
talking about just need to stitch
maybe we can start there you know is is
this stitching question
realistic for example is that something
you've seen in in practical applications
yeah that's a that's a really great
question i'm glad you asked that and i i
think this maybe is a good
time for me to reveal a little bit of a
maybe a dirty secret about the qt op
results too so i talked about how
well we found that the the online
fine-tuning version did better than the
offline rl version
what i didn't mention is that we
actually worked pretty hard to get the
offline rl version to work well
and most of what we did is alter the
data collection strategy
so you know one thing we found is that
more randomized
data collection strategies do better and
in retrospect it's not surprising why
that's the case if you have a more
randomized data collection strategy then
the support of your data is larger which
means fewer things are out of
distribution
so if we were more careless about that
we would have gotten worse results
uh for the offline setting but probably
still pretty good results for the online
setting
in regard to the stitching case i do
think that's actually very realistic
and i think it's also very important
because i think that's the main way that
we're going to get offline rl methods
that do better than the best behavior in
the data set
so i think kind of the the sanity check
for your offline rl method the test that
it really needs to pass is
if you take the best data in the data
set and you run behavior cloning on that
you really should be doing much better
than that and one way that you can do
much better than that is by combining
parts of existing trajectories that are
not by themselves
optimal but when combined together in
the right way result in more optimal
behavior and that's basically the
stitching thing
so i think we have to have offline rl
methods that can do that otherwise
they won't improve on very naive
baselines
that was a very nice talk and a quick
question which is for the
stuff at the end when you're showing the
conservative q learning and you were
demonstrating that it was in fact a much
more realistic and lower bound estimate
of q
were you using the alpha that was
specified in the theory or were you
using um other forms of alpha
yeah good question um so this is another
place where i have to admit
a small dirty secret um yes the theory
prescribes a value for alpha
i have no idea how to evaluate the
theoretically prescribed alpha
so in practice you have to select it you
know somewhat heuristically
through some cross-validation voodoo and
i think actually an important open
problem is how to
figure out automatically i think that
should be possible we don't have a way
to do that i'm actually really glad that
you mentioned also in your talk this
kind of cross-validation stuff i think
that that's really
one of the big outstanding challenges
not just for cql but for many other
methods because we always have some type
of parameters that we end up with which
we
kind of have to sweep under the rug but
that's that's a really big deal
i see an empty square in my zoom uh i
don't know if this is a question
lee hong we only have a question um
yeah so uh if i may um so study this
great talk
um so in in the cql objective
the first term you're penalizing the
discrepancy from
the data in a sense right and promoting
actions are more frequently chosen
have you thought about other
alternatives that have a similar
behavior
and trying to feel and see which one how
they compare to each other
yeah yeah that's a good question so uh
as with all research projects we
experimented with a whole bunch of
random stuff
uh and some of that stuff worked well
but we had no idea how to explain it so
we
didn't write about it because we didn't
understand it so one thing that kind of
seems to work is like just drive your q
values to be close to zero
so you know so take q value minus zero
squared
uh i think it works for much the same
reason and drives down erroneously large
q values
i think in general there's probably a
family of methods that will all have a
similar effect essentially things that
drive down q values at actions that
where the q
values are large and then you have to
counterbalance it with some other term
that prevents just driving everything
down
and for us that's the data term in fact
in the paper we actually
do present kind of a family of methods
and that family is defined
by different objectives from you
different objectives for the adversarial
distribution
so the version that results in this a
kind of elegant expectation under mu
minus expectation under
um uh data thing actually has an entropy
regularizer on mu
you could imagine a cross entropy
regularizing you could imagine some
other regularization term and those
would all yield slightly different
algorithms
um i think we'll take oh
go ahead leon sorry yeah i'll just say
thanks
i'll do them in order in fact so there
was a question with maybe you can take
two more questions there was a question
from zhao how on yao on the on the q a
uh and i think this is actually also
maybe a question for the
the panel modulated discussion later um
are there policy-grade
algorithms that could be used sergey
here instead of q learning
yeah yeah there are um i'm sure emma can
say a lot more about this
uh because she's actually done actual
work on this but
uh yeah in fact many of the classic
algorithms for this are policy grading
algorithms with some
variant of important sampling and
there's a lot of really fascinating
analysis that we can do in terms of you
know sample complexity and
guarantees for those kinds of methods so
i completely skipped over that in my
talk because i have 20 minutes and i
can't cover everything but that's that's
a huge part of the literature
thank you very much emma i'm looking
forward to your answer maybe at 11 30.
um one last question then we'll take a
break uh recover from zoom fatigue a
little bit
uh this is from chava who is asking uh
how much does this idea of stitching
rely on a markov assumption yeah um
so since this is the last question i'm
gonna take a little bit of time to
answer
probably because i think this gets at
some fairly deep uh
issues that i that i you know i just
want to mention in regard to offline rls
so the short answer is yes it does
the long answer is when you take a bunch
of data
that shows behaviors with different
levels of optimality different returns
and you're asking to do better than the
best thing in the data set there must be
some structure that you can exploit
if there's no structure then the best
you can do is just pick the max
so what is the structure that we
exploited offline rl was it's the
temporal structure
in fact if we make no further assumption
the temporal structure is kind of all
we've got
so we need to have some kind of
structure which means that we need to
have the markov property
to hope to do better than the best thing
in the data set
uh if you have observations if you're in
a pump dp setting well go and learn your
state space
so that you do have a mark of the markov
property and then you can do better
that makes sense well thank you very
much sergey thank you all for this
first uh for first three talks and
accommodating the virtual schedule
uh this is a phenomenal start to a
workshop which
uh which promises great things um so on
this note we're going to take a half
hour break
to be back at um struggling with time
zones here to be back at 1 30 uh
eastern time or 10 30 pacific time
um for one more talk no i'm getting this
wrong you're right um we're going to be
back at 2 p.m eastern time
uh an 11 pacific time and um
for one more talk by ophea nahum and
then we will have a discussion
uh at 11 30. so thank you all
for this the morning morning talks and
i'll see you in half an hour